sophie boisseau du rocher merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de manifestants et
étudiants dans les rues cet après midi
dans la capitale est ce qu'on peut
parler d'un rassemblement qui s'annonce
comme historique
écoutez en tout cas il s'annonce réussie
donc c'est un premier point les
manifestants effectivement atteignent un
nombre suffisant pour inquiéter le
gouvernement et montrer que la
mobilisation est sérieuse la
manifestation doit durer 48 heures donc
on va attendre jusqu'à demain
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que eux ils
ont largement dépassé la barre des 10000
participants
c'est déjà un succès alors dans le passé
d'autres mouvements sociaux ont été
réprimées dans le sang dans le pays
à dix mille policiers anti émeutes sont
mobilisés pour cette manifestation qui
se veut pacifiste est ce qu'on peut
craindre des violences de la part des
forces de l'ordre ou les autorités n'y
ont pas intérêt
écoutez je crois que les autorités n'y
ont pas intérêt à court terme en tout
cas ce que revendique ce mouvement
d'abord au delà de 2 des réformes c'est
son aspect pacifique et précisément il y
a une je dirais une un une atmosphère
relativement bon enfant ils savent
parfaitement que le gouvernement a
intérêt à durcir le mouvement et donc
ils ne veulent pas tomber dans ce piège
et résiste autant que possible à des à
des provocations de l'armée et restent
pour l'instant sur un mode
particulièrement pacifiques et non
violents alors cette jeunesse réclament
le départ du premier ministre la
dissolution d'une assiette de
l'assemblée nationale la réécriture de
la constitution
est ce que ce sont des voeux pieux
écoutez oui et non alors non ce ne sont
pas des voeux pieux parce qu'on sait que
depuis depuis de nombreuses années au
moins depuis dn la fin des années 90
c'est à dire depuis la crise économique
de 90 et politiques d'ailleurs pris
politique ces revendications sont au
coeur des demandes de la jeunesse
maintenant précisément on a vu que
depuis ses années de 90 le gouvernement
les intérêts acquis les élites l'armée
n'ont pas intérêt à fléchir et au
contraire se sont organisés pour
désamorcer ces demandes
donc la question c'est est ce que la
jeunesse va au bras de fer ou pas où est
ce qu'on va aller au contraire vers une
compromis qui sera de toute façon
bancale qui sera de toute façon
insuffisant mais qui permettra en tout
cas peut-être sur le terrain quelques
avancées notamment sur le terrain
constitutionnel le premier ministre
pourrait faire des concessions
finalement alors le premier ministre ne
va a déjà annoncé un que certaines
concessions étaient inenvisageables
notamment la réforme de la monarchie en
revanche sur certains points notamment
d'un des amendements à la constitution
il est prêt à quelques négociations
alors voilà maintenant il y a trois
demandes importantes de la part des
étudiants
d'une part la réforme de la constitution
d'autre part la fin du harcèlement des
des manifestants et le troisième point
c'est la dissolution du parlement
là je crois que on ira sur un sur un
petit accord qui sera le des réformes
constitutionnelles à la marge on
entendait un jeune dans le sujet
précédent parler de corruption des
élites c'est un fait dans le pays la
corruption est très présente et en tout
cas il y a effectivement une corruption
vous avez tous entendu parler du
scandale de la thai airways la thai
airways qui est temps de faillite
pourquoi parce que
elle assure payer l'achat d'un avion qui
ont en fait et c'est cette
surfacturation a servi à payer quelques
quelques personnes bien positionné donc
il y à une corruption qui est permanente
qui est quotidienne et qui est
particulièrement bien mises en oeuvre
par les élites donc ce que veut la
jeunesse c'est précisément que cette
corruption cesse parce que les
inégalités dans ce pays sont absolument
abyssal important de la population
détient environ 60% des ressources et
cela veut dire qu'il n'ya aucun avenir
pour la jeunesse d'une part et pour les
moins favorisés d'autre part peut-être
amant pour conclure sur le système
monarchique
alors il ya des manifestants qui
contestent dans la famille royale
d'autres qui soutiennent au contraire la
royauté
alors que comprendre de l'état d'esprit
des thaïlandais par rapport à ce système
monarchique
écoutez je crois que en règle générale
les thaïlandais sont très attachés à
leur monarchie
tout simplement parce que c'est un
facteur identitaire très fort et un
facteur religieux également cependant le
roi actuel est une personnalité
controversée et évidemment cela n'aide
pas à favoriser si vous voulez une un
attachement aujourd'hui à la monarchie
par ailleurs ce roi actuel qui est qu'il
ya déjà 68 ans ne semble pas préparé sa
succession est donc le problème va se
reposer à la génération suivante
et donc il y à là effectivement une une
crise de la monarchie qui est due
d'abord à la personnalité propre du
monarque actuelle le roi vajiralongkorn
merci vous qui beaucoup sophie boisseau
du rocher je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheuse associée à l'ifri et
spécialiste de l'asie